[Applause]
all right that's got to stop at some
point anyway
i'm sitting here with the rock don't let
that power go to your head all right
enchant the rock's name you will do my
bidding
aren't you tempted to make these people
like do something for you
go get all the money at citibank bring
it to the rock
uh you know speaking of actually
speaking of heads i talk to a lot of
people here you got a giant melon right
there right here i know i'm just i am
observing i
i'm in no way trying to oh i'm oh no
conan chan hold on a second
big head mcgee over here hold on well i
can bring it up because i have
i mean i have a frightening head people
are always talking about how big my head
is
no i do have a big head yeah like i was
told on saturday night live when i
hosted the show that it was myself and
ben affleck who we had the biggest
circumference so maybe it means more
brain matter i don't know or lack up for
that
yeah it doesn't work that way for me
there's just a lot of fat and bone up
here
now uh before we get on to other stuff
big big news you became a dad
three weeks ago i did yeah
congratulations
very nice did you have
uh boy girl baby girl baby girl yeah
what's her name simone it's a great name
yes yes that's really cool what's it
like is it you excited
um yeah yeah it's just extremely
exciting because it was my first
baby you know the funny thing is is is
that the hospital um
as soon as the baby's born you know the
baby comes out and and the
face is just completely running i know
babies look horrible when they're born
yeah and then what makes it worse is the
nurse is looking she goes oh my god she
looks just like you
you're like really yeah my head's not
bent yeah all right
i always think it takes babies like a
while to like before they start to just
oh that's a baby it looks good you know
what
well she's she's beautiful now yeah of
course oh my gosh
now let's talk about they're channing uh
rocky you got a lot of different
nicknames
some of which you've come up with i
believe is that or are they all given to
you
uh well it's a combination of uh myself
and writers and of course the fans they
they really come up with a lot of them
well there's
okay let's go through this the great one
great one okay you came up with that one
uh
you stole that one from me the people's
champ
people's champion the most electrifying
man in the world was ever seen
what's your favorite out of all laugh at
the rock no i do
i laugh with the rock i
bow to the rock what have you are you
working on any new ones is there is
there one that you that you want to get
out there that you want
i have one i've been i've been saying it
but it just hasn't stuck it's called big
long daddy from cincinnati
maybe if you have it put on your checks
try it now now of course we have to talk
about the eyebrow
how did the eyebrow thing get started
where did it begin when did you realize
you had this power
wow i would say back in college
university of miami okay
[Applause]
they're just applauding the notion of a
higher education
not that particular school yeah the
university of miami so what happened
when did you realize that people just go
crazy when you do that they love it uh
well i i
kind of used to do it i used to be in
the locker room and and guys would be
like hey dj what's going on i kind of
ignore him and give him the
right walk away
uh you know and then it would incite a
little emotion and guys but so then i
started doing it in wwf and it's become
ikonistic of the rock right now have you
ever thought of switching eyebrows to a
different eyebrow
well i'm not by eyebrow but i can do
is that on your driver's license not by
eyebrow only monobrow
cannot drive certain vehicles what you
so you can't you can't move that one
that nerve is just doesn't work no
no it doesn't work on the rocket i can
do both at the same time i don't know if
that's impressive
okay this is my this would be my
signature
that was a wrestler i would use i'd come
into the ring
if you had to wrestle me with that
strike fear in your heart
you saw my hair start moving around in
the ring oh no question
good that's what i want now you have uh
a new move
i guess that you're thinking of of
developing besides the eyebrow is that
right
i do well right now you know the rock
being the people's champion and being a
man of the people and having the
people's eyebrow and the people's own
you call it the people's eyebrows why
are you laughing at the rock i'm sorry
gotta stop doing that oh mighty rock
[Laughter]
uh there is one move in particular uh
and and i tell you if i do it tonight
it will be the very first time i've done
it right here this is exciting i want to
see this movie
what's the call do we need to know the
name first or
the name of the move the name of the
move will be called the
people's strudel
i can tell you already this will not
work let's see the people's screwdriver
max you want to give me a little
drumroll all right
[Laughter]
here we go
that's it max
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the people like the people's scooters we
just got to work out our timing on that
one
hard to know uh now the phrase you have
can you tell what the rock's cooking
okay hold on conan what one second it's
can you smell what the rock is cooking
i like my weight better
can you smell what the rock's cooking
okay this catch phrase
you whenever you go to a restaurant it
must bug the hell out of you
because people must come up to you all
the time
are you killing people yet when you go
into restaurants are you smashing them
over the head with chairs
and you know what the funny thing is is
regardless of of how
high brow the restaurant is it could be
the
the the one of the most exquisite
restaurants in the world doesn't matter
the mate or d
huh good i smell what you're cooking
cooks sending out
notes cooks sending out their little
chef hats we smell what you're cooking
send out a steak or two or something
dude
you're a little creative let's say yeah
you're cooking some shut up pies with
your fish
shut up pie let's try and use that on
them
now you've had a lot of success you're
getting some success in the movies now
you did the mummy returns yeah
absolutely big hit and now you're
working on the next one thank you
um you already shot you already shot the
next we shot it it's called the scorpion
king we wrapped it and it will be out uh
be out in april
now there's a lot of talk
there's a lot of talk that that this
means that you're going to be the next
big
action hero have you talked to in the
mold of arnold schwarzenegger have you
actually met schwarzenegger do you have
arnold's blessing
yeah absolutely he's been really really
supportive i've gone out to dinner with
her a couple of times he's come out to
see me perform at our show so he's been
great you know he's
he's hit me with the uh i'll rock your
fantastic rock
the people's eyebrow and everything
[Laughter]
that's a great impression that's right
you know he has been good and his
his whole family's been fantastic yeah
and there's a i heard a rumor that that
you're there's some pressure on you
to remake or revive one of arnold's old
big movies conan the barbarian is that
is that a possibility
why please don't that movie
ruined my life i actually heard that
somewhere
everywhere i hear you a barbarian
no leave me alone
where's your sword
that was my father uh
cheap but it worked before we go there i
i'm reading up on you today and i read
that you
shave your entire body now i would do a
lot of things
i would do a lot of things for my
profession i don't know if i would shave
my body first of all i don't need to
but secondly sad
i'm like a doll um but
what
why rock why do i say these things
but you actually shave your whole body
that that would be i mean
first what's involved in that does that
hurt
what's the preparation how do you do
this it's not like uh
you know where i'm at nasa trying to you
know send off a spaceship
you get your edge gel and your little
razor blade you just shave and
you know so i've been known to shave a
body part or two and you're a fellow
shaver and
you're still shaving the booty or
the classiest question i've ever been
asked
i had a special device made it's a seat
with whirling blades that i just sit on
ah nice uh
but do you have to use some kind of oil
or bomb or cream or something i mean
that would
well to go out i'll put on a little baby
oil and uh okay
you know i was uh why are you laughing
baby
there's a woman over there laughing
you're gonna rip the like the seats
apart
little baby oil yeah yeah oil of a
little bit of that oil of olay that's
for the ladies
i have recently recently switched to
neutrogena though by the way
nice that's more manly here
i'm going to stop now before you rip my
head off my shoulders
uh wilson congrats on return to the wwf
thank you this is excellent and look for
the scorpion king in theaters
next spring we were thrilled you could
come by and thanks for helping us out
with us
thanks for doing the rock everybody